hello everybody my name is Mark bar and
welcome to let's play paranoia yeah so
we're not loading up finally won't for
one we're not loading up right when the
monsters about to say this but we need
to get OC as soon as I walk over here
the music starts playing ok buddy
hubby da la da dee da da da oh no oh no
oh no oh no that's not good
oh now can't blame yourself
oh nothing oh my leg okay move shake it
off shake it baby
alright there we go so I don't know how
to get away from this thing but I'm
gonna try okay hang on
what's a stealth save epic stealth save
okay gimme nope nope not today
oh oh epic fake-out I think so yeah yeah
yeah okay hang on I can hey I'm a try
I'm just gonna do process of elimination
here go right in the fireplace and go
yeah BAE
I know these killed me before but I'm
gonna
ah damn it I could never get it it would
never be nice enough to just give it to
me on the first try why not why not why
not man
why not why hi kitchen try the kitchen
sink okay guy guy guy guy guy guy ah ah
ah ah
okay I'm gonna live around do the other
one in the kitchen and then I'll just
keep guessing until I go somewhere else
oh that was a little close there buddy
cupboards let's see there's the covers
in the kitchen and then in I did the
living room I reached I in the bathroom
one the traditional room is one just
below us so I think that's next on my
list
doctor doctor ha there's no way to get
there alright whatever okay we've got
the traditional room with the first
floor traditional room with the table
and the closet so that's next I hate
this process of eliminate whatever all
right whatever you know what I didn't
need to
I don't need any of your sass mr.
monster I'll mother of God I hope I
didn't bark this shape so that I can
never get away from him I hope not I
would be so upset because I would hate
to have to go okay dude
go there you go alright okay we got the
traditional room on the first floor and
hopefully that'll be maybe just hiding
like a coat rack I'm gonna try out at
the table first it's a little tight but
uh I'm here okay there's a traditional
room and after that you go into the
upstairs rooms and then there's a whole
bunch of places that you can hide up
there
so ah damn it
not up Ridge hahaha I hate these
controls sometimes it makes me just go
right past it like okay whatever ah go
down go right go right don't go down or
that way for you guys it's right for me
ah I'm a baby I'm a big baby it's gonna
take a while maybe I'm just gonna
fast-forward until I actually get it
because I don't think anything else
amazing is gonna happen so if this son
doesn't work I'm just gonna skip till I
get right because this is gonna take
forever otherwise hi friend how's it
going buddy Oh No
oh no someone else Oh No mmm okay going
upstairs all right be back in a second
Oh goddamn time holy crap man
oh man I literally went through every
eye oh man it was in the most right most
room in the top floor which meant that I
went through every single one before I
got to the right one son of a [ __ ]
why why would you do that to me I wasted
like 15 minutes ha ha but you guys
didn't see it okay morning again is jana
rama I can't stand this then leave that
thing's hand I still feel it on my leg
gross
I'm calling mom and going home about
time you got some freaking sense inside
your head let's call mama and get out of
here nah rare you know that the movie
mama
okay whatever screw it scratch on up cha
I'm gonna put the phone up to my ear and
there's gonna be hairs just right into
my ear I know you're awake mom good boob
hello Miki it's so early what do you
want
sorry um can I go back home for a while
huh what are you talking about I don't
know did something happen yes evil
monsters it's not that big of a deal
there's just some problems yes it's a
big deal I'd like to come back please
it's too late for that now I don't know
what happened but no oh that's your home
now don't call me about this stuff so
early in the morning woke your goodbye
your mom's kind of a [ __ ] isn't she
oh well that sucked I didn't think so
what do I do
how about you just get out of the house
done matter where go stay with myth from
miyabi mr. Miyagi whatever his name was
stay with him you know use your feminine
wiles to get as a 10
okay so do I have a key I still have one
more key that I need to use which must
be for one of these rooms upstairs
correct correct
there we go all right but there's still
some locked doors so many oh that's
creepy uh okay don't like that okay a
bear feels so fluffy Abby's good doll
looks pricey nothing on the shelves
acute stuff bunny a my god don't do that
to me you son of a [ __ ]
is there key in it there key inside this
broken doll
this is dasn't meant a jumped scare wait
huh there's something in here a key
oh I thought in darkness I could find
the light but there was no going back
okay so in darkness could find the light
but there was no going back there was
that other room with a light switch is
that what you're talking about
I thought in the darkness see not in the
darkness I could find the light but bla
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla
okay so that room that is still wait is
it over here or over there I don't
recall where exactly it is but yeah was
in here hang on flick it damn it I
thought that was it oh man okay this
might take me a while oh here we go
why not the light switch wait what oh I
got to turn it on hang on what wait what
you're not doing anything off what what
nothing on nothing frickin happened what
uh nothing's happening I don't know what
to do wait a minute no this doesn't wait
hang on here we go okay ah I see well
now interesting the dressers empty
there's nothing on the shelves so what
am I supposed to wait oh oh under the
lampshade
there was a frickin key ah starting to
get angry I didn't notice with it off oh
good note
oh okay I thought something was gonna
happen there alright so I got one more
key this room was open right yeah this
room was already open I don't have the
code for that thing so I have to go over
her oh this one is already open oh yeah
that one was open okay the top ones on
open yes I think that is the last door
that is the very last door looks like
the master bedroom okay lotions and such
some contraceptives uh-huh maybe I can
invite over mr. miyabi for some path
when you gaze long into the abyss the
abyss also gazes into you okay my
immediate thought is the well like the
well looked like bottomless right it
looked like a very empty well so stopped
at 9 okay that's probably an important
clue the alarm clock stopped at 9 box of
tissues collecting dust piece of paper
gazing longing to the abyss the abyss
also gazes into you so let's check the
well outside this is just me trying to
use my logic here just me all 100% brain
power and it's paid off
everyone just hush your mouth for a
little bit while I work I'll work my
magic okay alright watch this too dark
to see yeah alright something shiny on
the inside is it oh don't know there's
no more locked doors ah it's just too
far away there ah oh
oh-oh-oh
no way I fell in I'm so far down uh-oh
somebody oh okay
yeah I'm looking for it oh wait this the
wall looks kind of brittle so I'll try
breaking it with this rock maybe I can
get a foothold okay
uh-oh oh I broke a hold door in wall
here let's go in right away oh I don't
like this can I save is it really this
much space under the well that's
ridiculous but it's possible it may lead
to the surface I'll keep walking then an
underground tunnel filled with horrific
entities and wanted nibble all my
giblets right right right
huh I knew it go right
please don't be amazed and let me save
again magic saving up right down left
down right sound amazed but it's a
big-ass tunnel right down almost to the
end I think maybe it's a little bit left
ok maybe not all right
panic has settled I'm no longer
perturbed by this ok is this the end
here coming up in the end and shubbu ski
suite oh god more okay if they expect me
to be panic throughout this entire thing
they're sorely mistaken right now it's
just kind of
okay navigate super awesome race it's
like I'm playing Mario Kart you know
just kind of rounding the corners quick
as I can
pixelated graphics trying to get trying
to finish this race in first place
that's what I'm really trying to do here
and come on
hang on I must save this in case you
know don't want any surprising to have
to go through all that again
okay I'm done with that I'm not good
anymore let's just hurry up and get
through this so that we can move forward
go on a merry way have a good time happy
fun time no more no more really more
okay here we go oh whoa whoa whoa whoa
hey now what you doing to me
oh whoa
stop it hey stop being weird
Oh's with the legs ah come on no I
that's not good huh yeah kabura
bring me my camera mr. Kimura uh uh it's
it's really the acting that I put into
this game that makes everyone wants to
watch my legs face ah mr. Miura are you
okay miss dr. Nakamura I'm lowering the
Rope for you you you wait right there
there
okay my hero
you don't seem hurt but you should go to
the hospital sorry for barging into the
garden but you didn't answer the doorman
Bell so I came in and wait where's your
eyeballs miss Nakamura Wow mr. Guevara
well what's wrong wrong road enough I
hate this I wanna I wanna go home
interesting so she finally broken a
monster there's a monster in the house
really since the day I moved in
something inhuman non-animal has been
stubbornly follow after me even down in
that well cave it was chasing me and
it's not just a monster there's been
hair in the water and faxes in pianos
playing themselves and strange voices I
can't take it I'm scared of course I am
just hold me in your big strong arms I
just want to feel safe it's immediately
hard to believe it's true - really it's
some kind of zombie zombie I wouldn't
lie about this I see perhaps it's not a
mashup of some kind of wild animal okay
I understand stay at my place for today
huh
really I've lived there for five years
and never met such a monster you should
be fine there the monsters gonna follow
you and murder you I'll look around this
place while you sleep tonight no don't
do that no no don't do that that's a bad
idea there's no need to don't know
don't be ridiculous it's bad don't do
that that's bad I know you're big and
strong but you're not quite like me you
can't survive it ooh nice place you got
here
your rooms very clean haha just don't
have too much stuff by the way miss
Nakamura I ask you something
are you single hmm imagine having an
illness what kind of illness is it sorry
if it's rude
depression I take antidepressants I'm
writing a serial story so I see then you
really must relax leave the monster to
me thank you very much you like how we
stand on top of our chairs also miss a
key I'd like you to tell me about her
miss Amy pouch from illness yes I
thought it was odd since she didn't seem
unhealthy last I saw of her
my aunt killed herself in that house oh
it was suicide I didn't know do you know
why she got married in ten years ago
started living in that house she had a
hard time but she got pregnant after
five years she and her husband were very
glad but the child was stillborn my aunt
always blamed herself my uncle uncle got
tired of trying to support her and left
the house since then she kept getting
strangers she started saying she always
being watched or judged my mom and I
were only family we should have
supported her but we couldn't cuz your
mom's kind of horrible my mom has
terrible hysteria and she has always
been prejudiced against her little
sister my aunt calls my mom called my
aunt crazy and a murderer she wanted
nothing to do with her I was afraid of
my mom so I ignored all of it though I
knew my aunts pain if I have been brave
and supported her and taking her to the
hospital it would have never happened
that day I went to the house without my
mom knowing I was worried for my aunt
she'd hung herself on the second floor I
screamed the rope snapped and she fell
to the floor my mom didn't want the
house she didn't even want to be
reminded of my aunt when I was diagnosed
with the depression my mom recommended I
go there said it was good house for the
crazies I'm sure she meant to imply that
I might die as well man your mom really
is kind of a [ __ ] I gone saying too
much I know it's not pleasant I'm sorry
it's all right you've had a very rough
please take care of yourself I'll go
take care of this monster now make
yourself at home sleep whenever you want
you can use the bed there no um I
shouldn't I can use the sofas or the
floor now don't be ridiculous someone
someone so pretty can't sleep on the so
uh
oh I'm so embarrassed Oh I'll sleep on
the sofa oh you're pretty oh no don't
look at me
oh so shy oh you're uh you're here at ok
ah guy see some balls I'll sleep in the
bed
screw you know I don't feel bad use his
bed I'd use his bed and dong dong Oh
what you gonna do what you gonna do
she's sleeping soundly that's good
nothing seems wrong with the house oh
I'll take a nap too in the bed ok
day 4 nothing bad happened oh man I
thought something bad was gonna happen
oh ok alright then oh well Dave oh let
me guess more dialog as soon as it's
over or is mr. Miyagi's mr. Easley Oh
who's that
is that mr. Miyagi oh oh ah oh no I'm
back in the house I'm back in the house
oh crap why why am i back it doesn't
could it be mystery aura did he bring me
back here no don't want to be here
another I have to save actually so I'm
actually all that time I ran over
because I lost track of time cuz I
skipped that big segment there so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
I
yeah
Oh
No
your mouse occurs
okay nobody's stupid
sir as her